où avez-vous obtenu cela d'une boîte de
cassettes VHS PDG des propriétaires jusqu'à KB Kirsty je
veux que vous vous concentriez nous devons trouver
plus de ces bandes regardez cette caméra
il y a comme évidemment quelque chose qui se
passe ici si bizarre il y a cette chose que
je '  je prends l'appareil photo j'ai entendu parler de la
photographie spirituelle avant je ne l'ai
jamais vu en personne que
faites-vous ici elle parle à l'envers elle
dit Bloody Mary tout ce qui
se passe est lié au visage elle n'a jamais
rien dit de tel avant
qu'il soit  va m'emmener et si quelqu'un avait
conspiré pour que nous soyons dans cette maison
ce n'est pas une coïncidence
je crois qu'elle fait partie d'une prophétie
[Applaudissements]
leur activité normale comme s'il n'y avait
rien derrière
toi DeeDee